[Musique]
l'article 3 de la charte canadienne des
droits et libertés est clair tout
citoyen canadien a le droit de vote et
intéligent et vos élections législatives
fédérales et provinciales
mais aussi important soit-il ce droit
n'a pas toujours été accordée
équitablement à l'ensemble de la
population
la première élection canadien s'est
tenue en 1867
mais les femmes elles qu'on peut obtenir
le droit de vote avant 1918 et stockton
vivant dans les réserves
eux ont dû attendre jusqu'en 1960 pour
voter puis en 1993 ce sont les personnes
vivant avec une déficience
intellectuelle
les juges qui ont obtenu ce droit les
détenus ont aussi été privés pendant
longtemps de leur droit de vote
ce n'est que depuis 2002 que tous les
détenus peuvent voter en milieu carcéral
plus récemment l'an dernier ce sont tous
les canadiens vivant à l'étranger qui
ont obtenu le droit de voter qui veulent
un peu il avait refusé aux ex pétri qui
avait quitté le pays depuis plus de cinq
ans la cour suprême a aussi donné raison
aux électeurs outre-mer ils sont quand
même un million l'âge légal pour voter a
aussi changé dans l'histoire depuis 1977
à 18 ans que tous les électeurs peuvent
déposer leur bulletin dans l'urne
avant il fallait 21 ans s'il s'est
élargie depuis un siècle
en fait un seul groupe s'est vu retirer
le droit de vote des citoyens
britanniques pouvaient voter aux
élections canadiennes
jusqu'au milieu des années 70
aujourd'hui tous les citoyens canadiens
de plus
8 heures on le droit de voter sauf une
personne le directeur général des
élections
[Musique]